I bet you didn't know crop rotation
could be your Farm's secret weapon let's
dive into how it works crop rotation is
like giving your soil a vacation instead
of planting the same crop year after
year switch it up grow corn one year
beans the next and maybe wheat after
that why different crops use different
nutrients corn might gobble up nitrogen
but beans will fix it right back into
the soil it's like Nature's perfect
balance and guess what rotating crops
can outsmart those pesky pests and weeds
they hate change so by mixing things up
you keep them guessing Plus your soil
gets a break different Roots improve
soil structure and health think of it as
a spa day for your Fields so give crop
rotation a try your farm will thank you
with healthier soil better yields and
fewer pests that's a win-win win see you
next time and Happy farming